sean-o harris got a couple of Super Bowl
rings he didn't wear him today with the
New York Giants he works for the NFL
Network you can follow him on twitter at
Shawn O'Hara 60 which is my Sleep Number
you can see Shawn every Sunday on NFL
Network's NFL gameday first it's 7:00
a.m. Eastern starting this weekend
thanks for joining us great to see again
what were you expecting to happen last
night great question you know I was
expecting Carolina to really just
completely take over the game and I
thought they did in the first half but
it's almost like they ran out of gas and
and it looked to me like two totally
different teams the first half Carolina
I mean they I watched
always watching the offensive lineman
obviously but I could tell after every
little play there was a little extra
shove I everybody which meant to me that
they're still I mean I know coach speak
always says hey we're done with the
Super Bowl were past it but they weren't
clearly and I mean there was some big
time hitting going on on both sides of
the ball so it was a very physical game
but in the second half
I thought Carolina can't kind of ran out
of gas even though they they should have
won the game I mean it's crazy to me
driving in this morning - coming up I'm
saying wow what a totally different
narrative this would have been if if
Cano makes the kick now I mean if they
win that game and he and he makes that
kick
I think everybody's saying Carolina's
going back to Super Bowl that's what
everybody's thinking do you guys do we
look at Trevor's Simeon differently if
he loses his debut as opposed to winning
by one I think the way that Cam drove
them down at the end of the game I don't
think anybody would have blamed that
loss on Simeon and you know the people
look at the stats say well he threw two
picks well the first one was a screen
pass that was tipped as a fluke and the
second one was a great decision he just
was getting hit there was a free Blitzer
and any you know under threw the ball a
little bit so it was a great decision
just didn't work out for him but I don't
think anybody would blame Simeon if they
lost that game I thought he looked
poised I thought he looked a lot better
than I thought he would look made a lot
of good throws
that offense you don't get to set your
feet a whole lot when you're a
quarterback so you've got to make a lot
of athletic throws you're kind of on the
run so he'll get better with some of
that but but you've been in the huddle
before when a quarterbacks come in and
you realize as a veteran uh-oh what's
that what's that feeling like you know
there's without naming me when when a
young quarterback comes in so when Eli
comes here when a cable TV UI comes in
you could tell wait wait what's a bad
comedian so cable Eli comes in and he's
like you know the big guys and you could
tell he's just trying to memorize the
play and try he's trying not to screw it
up you know it strips right you know
dice right get the formation go and make
sure he's lined up you know counter 34 y
tango alert 62 firm I mean when he when
cable I said it's trips right 34 Y tengo
alert 6262 firm it's like all right
really know when DirecTV Eli comes in
all right guys listen up don't buddy
jump cuz we're going on the hard count
all right it strips right counter 34 y
tango alert alert 62 firm all right hey
Odell I want you to just go deep all
right just do your dance do your thing
you know that's the difference between a
quarterback that's been there done that
has the confidence has the swagger as
opposed to you know cut you know what do
they call a crowning a Tony Romo crowny
you know when he was making the cupcake
brownies you have DIRECTV yes okay I was
gonna say well I'll take care of you i
hook you up yeah I mean I still pay the
bills so yeah is that what you're
offering Fritzi make some calls see we
get Shawn got both I got to do both
sorry do you think that Cam Newton is
officiated different than other
quarterbacks
he was last night now here's what I'll
say
this was the first game for the referees
- you know people forget that human
element I don't think they were missing
calls because it was Cam Newton I just
missed calls but Shawn there was a
targeting play last night oh that's
college there was a couple I mean they
yeah cams a big guy there's a lot of
room to hit him yeah do you think that
was a conscious effort by Denver to go
up top on Cam Newton I don't think well
yes they did it with regular I think I
was shocked with how many
helmet-to-helmet
hits he took more Hall and cams not an
easy guy to go helmet to helmet on I
mean you want to go helmet to helmet on
Drew Brees I get it he's like 510 but
Cam Newton is 66 so you've got I mean
you've got to try to hit him in the head
so I was surprised they Wade Phillips
said if you're gonna go get him make
sure you go get him uptown no I don't
think we fools would say that I don't
think they were coached to do any of
that I think it's just part of the game
but that part of the game I mean is in
the official hands but if it's their job
to stop it with the NFL ever have the
targeting rule that college football has
because if you're so conscious about
this yeah more so than colleges why
don't you have targeting in the NFL I
think their concern with them would be
that's one more thing to review and the
one thing that you know the NFL doesn't
want to do they don't want to slow this
game down but you don't you you won't
have to because if you get targeted now
they review it hey cuz because it's
Harding rule College you're out but what
did you guys tackle so yeah you're gonna
you're gonna reduce the number of hits
up top by saying to somebody if you get
caught or you know you do target you're
gone so aren't you going to then tackle
differently because you know that
there's a chance that you run that risk
of being tossed yeah I mean I I I'm with
you on that and I think that it would
have a huge impact yeah here I think the
challenge with the NFL which is
different than college you only got 45
guys so I mean if you lose a couple
games you are in one game now I mean
you're really behind the eight ball
college you may be able to to have a
couple other guys you probably got 95
guys on the cylon you could throw
another guy out there but it's okay it's
a good interesting topic but who's
responsible for
when he takes that one hit who's
responsible with making sure he's okay
where does it start
give me physically or he's down on the
ground yeah you can see for it's only
three seconds in real time yeah but he
got it was helmet to helmet and it felt
like he or it certainly seemed like he
was a little disoriented is it on the
Panthers is it that independent review
judge I'm supposed to be looking at his
linemen I guess cams not coming out cams
not coming out but I also will say this
cam has a flair for the drama so there
are times where he gets hit and and you
know I think he's cried wolf a few times
and unit so you don't know but there
were some egregious hits last night I'm
almost positive and I know just from
being on the sidelines when your
quarterback takes a big hit and you come
and he comes off a field everybody goes
up hey you okay man you all right your
court your quarterback coach hey man you
okay the head coach will probably come
or hey you all right everybody knows you
took a big hit so guys are coming over
and checking him and if he's not okay
there's plenty of opportunity especially
now with the way the culture has changed
to say hey you know what something
doesn't feel right but uh you know I
think everybody you know saw him
flossing his teeth and he said I was
eating oranges at halftime I don't know
when you take a big hit sometimes your
teeth kind of [ __ ] it doesn't wear a
mouth beat so I'm sure he was flossing
after the game too but it's something
that the NFL is definitely aware of and
I think everybody asked cam I'm sure are
you all right yeah but he's not gonna
tell you the truth I think cam is I
think he was okay now he's big enough he
could take those heads if that was
anybody but cam they probably wouldn't
finish that game last night
they probably woulda been out cuz he
took he took a shot I mean it's been to
the jaw and and I think a lot of other
quarterbacks their jaw might've him have
you ever ratted on Eli and said he's got
to come out or I think he's in trouble I
mean no not for injury I mean there may
be times I wanted Minnesota game comes
to mind in 2007 I think he threw three
three pick sixes I think I asked him if
he was colorblind being hurt having to
come back I will continue with Sean
O'Hair from the NFL Network you're able
to see him you got a big big weekend
right you started on Sunday at 7:00
Eastern
yeah Sunday game day first bit coach
Billick Melissa Stark Mike Robinson we
got out we get to start off the day you
know I'm a big Talladega Nights
Ricky Bobby fan so I love saying hey if
you're not first you're last so we're
the first ones out there I got a pretty
big big Sunday I got the I'm actually
calling the the bangles bangles Jets
game on radio - so I'm pulling yeah kind
of like you look good you last night
grace leave number zero yeah it's not 16
all right welcome back with Sean O'Hair
right after this Dan Patrick show what
do you guys drink before a game mm-hmm
everybody's different some guys like
Gatorade some guys think that's too
sweet any crazy stuff well you know for
the for the Molly hawkers as my college
defense I used to calls the Oh linemen
there's a lot of are you a sweat guy or
not sweat guy and the guys the sweat all
the time like me and deal were big-time
sweaters so you always had to worry
about the cramping aspect so I've drink
I've had to drink some awful stuff
before a game just to make sure if it's
a hot game that there's this stuff
called raw Hydra light and it literally
tasted like somebody took a sweaty towel
that somebody in my get soul cycle with
it's just so like in this mason jar
right and you couldn't sit but yet to
just go put because if you tasted it you
would gag so it was called rawhide
rehydrate that's a hell of a plug for
him - a little glass jar I mean you just
had to take it to the face you had to
take one for the team it takes like
David deal Oh tastes like sweat that's
all I could say that was pretty nasty
and then Gatorade came out with this new
their new endurance formula they called
it and it was a head also have extra
electrolytes extra sodium so guys would
really drink that but you know the funny
thing was I didn't my last couple of
years in a league I found myself really
craving a cup of coffee before that's
hot and that's how I knew it was time to
get out of the game when I was I wanted
a cup of coffee before the game
just to kind of wake the body up and
kind of get a little did you eat before
the game oh yeah
yeah you have to eat because the pregame
meal is 8:30 and then if you think about
it
kickoff set one you're not done with the
game till four o'clock so if you don't
eat a good meal I mean there were times
where I didn't eat enough breakfast
early on in my career and I would I
would be shaking and sweating I would
being almost like a sugar crash at the
end of the game because I hadn't eaten
anything so and so long so pregame meal
was huge had to do that now the funny
thing is you could we always knew what
Chris Snee ate for breakfast for a
pregame meal because he would Chum
before every single game on the
sidelines just Chum you had to watch out
because he would Chum on your shoes like
there was no warning or whatsoever so he
throw up before every game he threw up
before every game this kind of was his
ritual that's how we we knew it wasn't
time to go out on the field until sneak
puked Danny by puking a huddle I think
so Burt might've sober was a big dry
Hever so he he would throw up in the
locker room he was so nervous and that's
when I was just texting him this morning
he's got his first he's a high school
football coach he's got his first high
school game tonight motion to watch on
Hills in New Jersey and he said you know
wish me luck guys it's our first game in
the first response on the text read was
are you gonna puke as the coach imagine
being a high school kid irritating your
coaches over there yakking in the corner
so yeah we waited Super Bowls you did
guys did it's different
did guys get sick before the Super Bowl
no I didn't notice anybody I mean it's
new threw up of course of course and
sober was in the invocation dry heaving
in the shut in the stall and I'm fertile
bit of here but he never actually
produced anything but yeah I didn't see
I didn't see anybody so you could just
hear it echoing out of the stall the dry
he was action could you hear it and
nothing comes out sneeze was into the
silent assassin you would never hear him
he would make a sound it was just
awesome you look down and there's red
beans and rice with radiator all right
yeah the most interesting matchup this
weekend is is what game there's so many
good game now I did say I singled out
the Eagles and browns because of course
in Winston or g3 yeah I wouldn't be
interested in this game in week 14 but
I'm very interested this weekend yeah I
think that game I equate that to that
that's interesting like like watching a
slow crash yeah like nobody's watching
that game because this can be a good
game everybody's want to see who's gonna
who's gonna get knocked out of the game
first Carson Wentz or RG 3 maybe
yeah I'm not to that degree but I'm
curious how accessible to me yeah I
don't know either that's that one you
know I don't even know of course and
once is still healthy I mean a week ago
he had ribs the ribs 60% yeah healed so
that's interesting
RG 3 what about dak Prescott is a rookie
yeah the Giants Cowboys game I mean
obviously being a former giant I'm
watching that game but there's so many
great storylines in that game dak
Prescott to me
I'm he looked phenomenal in preseason I
thought the ball came out of his hands
very Warren Moon like he just throws
that tight spot the ball just jumps out
of his nuts about as good a compliment
as you can yeah I don't want to put I
don't want to put but I'm just saying
though his throwing motion and the way
the ball 5 Sean O'Hair compares Prescott
to Warren Moon yeah that'll be a but
here's the wrinkle that I think that
Prescott brings to that offense that
makes him even more dangerous he can run
the read option you're not gonna run the
read option with Tony Romo you're to you
can't get him hit you can't put him at
risk but him running the read option
with Ezekiel Elliott and Alfred Morris
behind the best online in the NFL that's
a tough stop right there that's a tough
and I never understood that they would
do the read option with Sam Bradford in
Philadelphia and he was never running
the football right well that's why they
couldn't run the football because that
was ineffective nobody nobody cared and
actually Chip Kelly remember when Sam
Bradford got hit by Terrell Suggs in the
preseason yeah and Chip Kelly said well
I thought they couldn't hit the
quarterback and they said well chip
because if you're pretending to run the
football he is fair game and that's they
stopped running the read option which is
why their run game really
was inefficient last year but that's
that that's gonna be a great matchup I
mentioned the Bengals Jets came I think
that that that's you know to quality
playoff like playoff caliber teams I
think that's gonna be a good game well
the Sunday night game is gonna be
interesting
with Garoppolo again oh yeah Cardinal
defense I mean when a schedule came out
everybody say wow it's great game brady
and carson palmer you know i mean the
air is kind of out of that balloon a
little bit Jimmy Garoppolo no disrespect
to him but I don't like to say Aaron
balloon with Tom Brady yeah yeah that
was a 40-inch let's see yeah it's
rivalry with the Patriots there
what if Colin Kaepernick's your teammate
yeah I've got a lot of respect for Colin
my the thing I guess I'm disappointed
with with how that one I think it's a
great cause and am I saying has always
been you can never gain and garner
respect for a cause by showing
disrespect to something else and I think
him taking a knee is much it's it's a
step in the right direction as far as
showing respect still but I to me the
flag stands for so much more and for all
the soldiers and everybody overseas
everybody that's fought for our our
country I've got so much respect for
that so I think there's a better
platform to do that on would you say
something to him if he's a teaming I
would provide have a conversation with
him and say hey man I I think we're all
with you we support you in this cause
for equality but let's find a way to do
it without taking away from the team
well I do think it's getting lost of
what he said initially and how people
are interpreting this that he's
disrespecting the fly you know men and
women who fought for our country you
know the great police officers that we
do have it that that's not what he means
but that's how people have interpreted
that I don't know if that's his problem
or it's our problem that we're not
seeing or hearing what he's you know
dispensing there yeah and and I think
that's I'm glad he came back and
clarified I'm glad he's kind of changing
because sitting down to me was was very
disrespectful now by taking me saying
look
still honoring all of those things and
he's not he's trying not to be
disrespectful towards what we all feel
like the flag represents sure the NFL
make everybody stand the NBA does I
would be okay with that if they said no
listen we're gonna make everybody stand
and you know what I would be okay with
it because I would say this is something
that we do as an NFL it's part of being
an NFL player I don't think they can ask
us to do enough as NFL players so there
there are plenty of other platforms and
ways to create support to create
conversation and that would be my that's
really my only issue with all this is
that now when everybody talks about the
49ers right now they're not talking
about the team they're not very good so
there's nothing wrong about it's and and
I've always you notice I I played under
Tom Coughlin it was always about the
team team first team last team always
anything that distracts us from the team
is bad I mean that to put everything in
black and white so this situation is
it's a distraction for your team now I
think it's great that he's putting
himself out there and then he's creating
conversation because if Colin Kaepernick
hadn't done any of that people wouldn't
we wouldn't be talking about if the
Niners or Colin right now so I think
he's got to follow through on it which
it sounds like he is before I let you go
is your watch move forward it is now is
that because of Tom Coughlin yeah my
watch right now right now it is 1055 so
you're seven minutes ahead of time yeah
is that because of Coughlin yeah all my
all my all my clocks are fast cuz
Coughlin said if you're on time you're
late
yeah Johnny time just started five
minutes early now it's if we have time I
real quick it's kind of a kind of
messing with you because you don't let
me take a quick break yeah okay I'll let
you tell that we'll continue with the
Shawn O'Hara Shawn O'Hara we can't get
rid of him
NFL Network analyst you can follow him
on the NFL Network's NFL gameday first
7:00 a.m. Eastern starting this Sunday
all right before the break that was
around her
clip right there right can't get rid of
him no oh but I do logic chick-chick my
god alligator and his great of an actor
as he is when he John Malkovich's had a
man his money like you're better than
that hey the man has money yeah alright
so before the break you down a monster
you set your your clock ahead on your
wristwatch
six minutes fast yeah because and that's
Tom Coughlin would always say you guys
got to be five minutes early
yeah so you know when you first come to
the Giants the first couple years you
know anytime we had a new player we just
said hey look man just don't try to
fight it you can't you're not gonna win
everything starts five minutes faster
start setting your own watches five
minutes fast because you would drive up
to the facility and if you looked at the
clock on your car if it's automatically
said you know if the meeting starts at
eight o'clock you pull in at 7:50 and
you think I've got 10 minutes I'm gonna
go into the bathroom grab a bottle of
water I'm good you walk in the building
and it's seven fifty seven you're almost
late to the meeting yeah I mean you just
it was like a time warp you know it only
took you 30 seconds to walk into the
door but you lost seven minutes so so
players you had to figure it out but the
interesting thing is we would sit around
and talk about it because all right if
if you are just changing the clocks to
be five minutes fast but yet the meeting
is still starting at 8 o'clock basically
in the building we're starting at 7:55
but the clock still says 8 o'clock so
you're really not five minutes fast
because if you really want to be five
minutes fast and the 8 o'clock meeting
would just start when the clock said 755
that's technically five minutes or
generally but we're going on time but
this the clocks were five minutes ahead
of everybody else in the world so it's a
little bit of a mind yeah it is yes you
just do this blue Seaton's head there
yes sorry see more so so technically if
you set the clocks five minutes fast and
then you arrive five minutes earlier oh
my god you're not you're ten minutes
fast yeah my god yeah before I let you
go paulie's boyfriend is JJ Watt just
just friends did you uh did you ever
block JJ Watt or at least try to no no I
never I never had the pleasure of trying
yeah he's got go-go gadget arm so it
would have been a challenge I would
think I would have cut him on the first
play just to make him think about it
like hey man
oh yeah guess what I'm cutting you all
day long and now he's like all right
every time he starts coming my way he's
gonna start thinking about protecting
his knees and now you got him right
where you want it but yeah gigawatts
he's a special guy for for a guy his
size to be able to still have that shake
and have that move he's he's a special
special player the tough is the one guy
though defensively was it as far as
getting to the passer who would it be
that I played again yeah I'm excited we
got seen John John Randle little less
than a minute a minute real quick John
Randle I was playing for the Cleveland
Browns playing right guard we played him
when he was in Seattle up in Seattle and
I remember watching film on him leading
up to that game and I would try to write
down hey special moves they had spin
move did this guy have like a great club
moved yeah
like John Randle had them all he had
every move in the book he he was like
playing double dragon I mean he and I
remember in the game just thinking oh my
gosh like you beat him on the first move
he's got a second move ready and I was
most frustrated I've ever been in a
football game it's always great to see
you thanks for having thanks for the
stories we always lovely man the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience